bonsoir bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct ravi de vous retrouver dans dix
jours exactement
vous allez devoir choisir et pour vous y
aider dans cette émission chaque soir un
grand débat sur un grand thème de
campagne ce soir là des
2800 milliards d'euros question centrale
pendant des décennies qui semble avoir
complètement disparu de la campagne tous
les candidats ouvrent en grand et même
en très grand les vannes budgétaires
plus dépensiers que moi tu meurs
l'argent serait-il devenu magique est ce
que c'est si grave dans un contexte
d'inflation quatre experts ce soit pour
répondre à toutes ces questions stupeur
et tremblements en macro ni les proches
du président candidat serait de plus en
plus inquiète le scénario d'un deuxième
tour ric rac face à marine le pen afone
a tout sauf macron serait-il possible le
24 avril prochain nous poserons la
question à l'une des journalistes les
mieux informés sur les rides et elle
publie la nuit tombe deux fois chez
fayard qui raconte macro face aux défis
de l'autorité corinne lhaïk est avec
nous ce soir enfin dans le scam ce soir
l'oeil de blacko ausculte le duel
pécresse zemmour qui sera le mieux placé
au soir du premier tour benjamin grange
nous parlera de la sphère mckinsey du
point de vue des réseaux sociaux et puis
leur garde isabelle lasserre sur cette
petite musique qui monte sur la fin
possible la fin proche du régime de
vladimir poutine voilà pour le menu
cette fois c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs et s'ils voulaient tous
cramer la caisse on va donc s'arrêter ce
soir sur les dépenses des candidats et
les moyens de financer leurs programmes
avec une grande question pourquoi après
des décennies de rigueur la contrainte
budgétaire semble avoir disparu pour
tous les prétendants de l'elysée et
aussi pour les électeurs bonsoir mathieu
plane merci d'être avec nous est
économiste à l'ofce l'observatoire
français des conjonctures économiques de
sciences po bonsoir stéphanie villers
bienvenue économiste spécialiste de la
zone euro bonds soir benjamin lemoine
cette sociologue de la dette chercheur
au cnrs et à l'université paris dauphine
et vous publiez la démocratie
disciplinée par la dette j'ai hâte de
savoir ce que vous voulez dire par là
c'est aux éditions la découverte enfin
bon soir raphaël legendre consomme un
gain ravi de vous retrouver sur ce
plateau journaliste économique à
l'opinion je vous donne la parole dans
un instant mais on va d'abord faire le
point sur le coût des programmes des
candidats et vous allez le voir ce qui
ressort c'est que l'argent coule à flots
tour d'horizon signé nicolas coadou
au milieu d'un concert de promesses
c'est un indice de crédibilité majeur
dans une campagne présidentielle
le chiffrage des programmes donnent
droit à tous les cinq ans à une
surenchère 2 milliards financé 50
milliards
3 milliards d'euros si certains veulent
couper les vannes budgétaires d'autres
sont accusés de vouloir cramer la caisse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
42 milliards par an pour valérie
pécresse 50 pour emmanuel macron 60 pour
eric zemmour 68 pour marine le pen 93
pour yannick jadot mais la palme revient
à jean luc mélenchon 250 milliards et
fabien roussel 300 milliards ça commence
à chiffrer et encore faut-il pouvoir les
financer le candidat de la france en
soumises se targue d'avoir un équilibre
financier et promet des recettes au
moins aussi importante que les dépenses
les dépenses dans un premier temps
augmente mais génère des recettes c'est
à dire que ce que vous dépensez bas
comme c'est pas de logo vert en sable
regardante y en a plus mais ce sont des
salaires ce sont des constructions ce
sont des choses que l'on met en place
donc ça provoque à son tour du salaire
des choses que l'on met en place il
compte engranger 26 milliards d'euros
chaque année grâce à la lutte contre la
fraude fiscale problème à ce jour l'état
n'arrive à en capter que 3 milliards par
an autre formule magique du côté de
l'extrême droite marine le pen et eric
zemmour prévoit près de 20 milliards
d'économies en supprimant les aides aux
étrangers extra-européens là encore les
experts estiment cette économie à
seulement 6 milliards je donne toujours
les exemples de d'allocations familiales
allocation logement de rsa il n'y a pas
que ça mais il y en a beaucoup plus je
pourrais vous faire là mais vous allez
avoir faim si on commence à faire la
liste de toutes les plaies les
prestations sociales on donne aux
étrangers emmanuel macron pas en reste
table lui sur un retour de la croissance
et du plein emploi pour financer son
programme seulement le chômage n'est pas
descendu en dessous de 7 % depuis près
de 40 ans pour anne hidalgo c'est 10
milliards d'économies grâce au surplus
d'une croissance pourtant impossible à
prévoir sur le quinquennat
alors on va partir des chiffres beaucoup
de schering 8 milliards mais d'abord
ceux de la dette et des déficits
en france c'est l'insee qui publie ces
chiffres 2008 100 milliards d'euros pour
la dette c'est 112% 112,9 très
précisément du pipe du pib c'est la
banque de france à la source pardonnez
moi et puis les déficits on est à 6 5%
du pib à part valérie pécresse j'ai
regardé personne ne se préoccupe de ces
chiffres on al'impression on
al'impression franchement que ni les
candidats ni les électeurs ne
s'intéresse à ça comment vous
l'expliquez stephan weiler parce que
depuis la crise sanitaire on est rentré
dans une ère particulière où l'argent
coulait à flots on a bien vu que
et bien l'argent magique existait en
tout cas on a fait croire ça l'opinion
publique parce que la bce financer
l'ensemble ou en tout cas une grande
partie des dettes émises par les états
pour finances pour qu'il puisse les
états eux-mêmes financer les dépenses le
public puisque le quoi qu'il en coûte
est possible les français se disent on
est en plein de paraître absolument et
c'est une nouvelle c'est une nouvelle
donne on n'avait jamais connu ça
auparavant donc aujourd'hui c'est assez
difficile d'expliquer qu' il va falloir
que cette situation où l'argent est
facile c'est ce oui il ya un appel à
vigilance déjà sur sur ce plateau rafale
de jambes beaucoup d'observateurs se
disait après le quoi qu'il en coûte la
campagne elle va quand même se jouer sur
cette question là c'est la crédibilité
et le sérieux budgétaire va falloir
quand même penser aux générations
futures ça vous a surpris que ce sujet
là mais c'est seulement 12% des français
que ça préoccupe quand on les interroge
sur prêt ou pas surpris alors que les
français se soient jamais beaucoup
intéressé à la rigueur ça n'est pas une
surprise qui est plus inquiétant c'est
que les dirigeants eux mêmes ont
complètement lâché toute idée de
discipline budgétaire il faut se
souvenir il y a un an bruno le maire
ministre des finances olivier du soft
ministre du budget prométhée la fin du
quoi qu'il en coûte avec le
rétablissement de l'économie on sortait
d aide globale qui avait soutenu les
entreprises les salariés les ménages
pendant la crise de la colline mais il
était temps d'en sortir on a
effectivement les chiffres de l'insee
qui sont tombés cette semaine et qu'est
ce qu'on constate un déficit de 161
milliards d'euros en 2021 encore alors
même que le pib c'est à dire la création
de richesses dans le pays a retrouvé son
niveau d'avant crise au troisième
trimestre et on se rend compte qu'en
réalité les dépenses continuent
d'augmenter plein pot un rythme qui n'a
rien à voir avec celui qu'on a pu
connaître avant la crise donc dans ce
contexte là évidemment pas étonnant que
les français placent le sujet du
rétablissement des finances publiques et
de la dette en second plan mais c'est
vrai que c'est la passe de 1000 300
milliards celle record 300 milliards de
dépenses annuelles pour fabien roussel
benjamin lemoine vous qui est sociologue
comment vous expliquez cette ce
basculement malgré tout on se souvient
2007 bayrou avait fait de la dette et
des déficits son mantra on se souvient
aussi que françois hollande disait
attention à nicolas sarkozy en 2012 les
comptes sont mal gérées on se souvient
de françois fillon en 2017 qui avait dit
je suis à la tête d'un etat en faillite
est-ce qu'on est à ce qu'on est en train
de changer d'air on change de paradigme
où c'est conjoncturel parce que la crise
est passée par là mais il ya plusieurs
explications et ça a été rappelé par une
collègue économiste un instant c'est à
dire que l'action de la banque centrale
c'est vraiment ça qui a changé la donne
c'est à dire que il ya un verrou qui a
disparu qui est le verrou disciplinaire
des marchés financiers et pendant
plusieurs années les banques centrales
en assureront un rôle de filets de
sécurité pour l'économie mais aussi pour
les états a en quelque sorte calmer le
jeu et à calmer la donner a fait
disparaître ces verrous disciplinaire
des marchés financiers et ses taux
d'intérêt il ya plus de pression des
taux d'intérêt et elle commence juste à
resurgir donc j'aurais plutôt tendance à
dire que le paradigme d'avant les
banques centrales reprend un peu reprend
un peu pied tout doucement commencent à
se réinstaller dans le débat public ses
intérêts pourraient voilà mais en fait
augmenté on voit bien qu il mange bien
on voit bien que rien n'est totalement
fait que la banque centrale européenne
se laisse des marges de manoeuvre elle
parle de flexibilité elle regarde les
prévisions d'inflation à moyen long
terme et on prévoit 2% autour de 2% en
2024 ce qui est finalement tout à fait
raisonnable et elle laisse en quelque
sorte la porte ouverte et tout va se
jouer sur ce sur ce plan là c'est à dire
que l'opinion publique il a pas besoin
d'être dressé à la dette les français
n'ont pas besoin d'avoir leur opinion
publique dressé à accepter les mesures
d'austérité à venir le public elle a
besoin de s'intéresser à cela elle a
besoin de s'intéresser aux politiques
monétaires est en quelque sorte à qui
est plus ou moins frappés par
l'inflation est ce que c'est vraiment
néfaste à l'économie est-ce que c'est
néfaste à la société et qui pâtit de
l'inflation et qui potentiellement en
gagnent beaucoup beaucoup de sujets
économiques la politique monétaire dans
un contexte d'inflation déjà est ce
qu'on est en train de changer de
paradigme
vous voyez ça vous ou alors c'est
conjoncturel il faut quand même
revenir à une trajectoire raisonnable
même si on a compris que cette campagne
là dans les programmes ça n'est pas le
cas
ces changements de paradigmes il a eu
lieu j'allais dire même avant la la
crise sanitaire c'était le la grande
question macroéconomique c est ce qu on
ait durablement dans un monde à taux
zéro en fait
zéro taux d'intérêt zéro ce qui change
négatifs david et par le mondial très
abondante pas tellement d'investissement
au niveau mondial donc ça fait des taux
bas
des politiques monétaires qui était
extrêmement accommodante parce que
l'inflation monte pas et tout ça fait
que finalement le financement des dettes
a beaucoup baissé donc le coût de la
dette a diminué le grand paradoxe c'est
qu'on n'a jamais autant dette publique
depuis la préfecture 1950 en gros mais
la charge d'intérêt est vraiment un
niveau très bas charge d'intérêt
pour la rva il sort en 2007 c'était 3 %
du pib alors qu'on avait deux fois moins
de dette donc ça ça a été bien rappeler
la politique monétaire est fondamental
la question c'est jusqu'à quand cette
politique monétaire au ses taux bas vont
exister parce que on n'était pas face à
ce choc nouveau qui est un choc sur
l'énergie qui peut être durablement prix
d'énergie durablement élevé qui peut
changer même des effets de second tour
sur l'inflation et du coup là dedans la
politique monétaire c'est à dire il faut
essayer de comprendre vous notez
toutefois que moi je suis pas économiste
1 et vous nous dites en gros jusqu'à
présent les taux sont très bas
commencent à remonter ça c'est pas bon
pour financer la dette mais en même
temps l'inflation permet voilà d'avoir
une dette qui coûte du à remboursement
dettes un peu moins cher mais qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour piloter sa de façon fine
la question c'est qu'on le pilote c'est
la banque centrale d'abord qui est quand
même en délicatesse de piloter pour dix
neuf états membres qui sont pas
forcément dans les mêmes situations il
ya deux choses c'est que pour le moment
ces termes une situation de crise un
donc je pense que la gestion de
l'inflation est pas forcément la
priorité la question à mon avis sur le
quinquennat à venir c'est que on peut
imaginer peut-être qu'on va sortir de la
crise et qu'on va retrouver une forme de
normalisation des choses faut savoir que
si on n'en parle pas mais le pacte de
stabilité la fameuse règle des 3%
voilà a été mis de côté en tout cas
temporairement avec la crise coville est
là la guerre en ukraine mais ça va pas
dire que c'est sorti des tablettes pour
toujours donc et les règles budgétaires
peuvent revenir donc ça veut dire que ça
dépend de la bce sa dépendance européen
et bien sûr des allemands est donc tout
ça va être vraiment va conditionner
aussi la gestion publique et peut-être
qu'on va être rattrapé un moment donné
c'est la question donc ya beaucoup
d'incertitudes vont crds et m'en être
attrapé ça veut dire quoi en terme de
deux quotidiens pour les frangins par
existe déjà en fait pourquoi en fait on
croit que l'argent est magique parce que
justement ce pacte de stabilité a été
suspendu et c'est aussi une première
c'est à dire qu'avant il fallait qu'on
rende compte à bruxelles donc tous les
pays dispendieux dont faisait partie la
france avait bien du mal à arriver avec
son déficit public toujours au-dessus
invariablement au dessus des 3% ou
presque là on lui a dit et on a dit
aussi à tous les pays du sud de l'europe
parce qu'on n'est pas les seuls à
dépenser on leur a dit faites comme vous
pouvez financer la crise sanitaire donc
en fait c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui les
candidats ils n'ont pas besoin de se
soucier de sens puisque le pacte de
stabilité suspendu maintenant jusqu'en
2023 c'est à dire que ça devait être fin
2022 et avec la crise l'ukrainienne
maintenant c'est deux milliards rendez
vous l'année prochaine pour l'avenir les
candidats considèrent que ce n'est pas
une hypothèse de base à prendre dans
leurs modèles ces restrictions
budgétaires or le risque c'est ça c'est
que un jour en fait lorsqu'on va être
face à l'allemagne l'allemagne elle elle
n'entend pas revoir en fait sa rigueur
budgétaire non mais parce que les
décomptes les chiffres de l'économie
allemande ont parlé des piliers des pays
du sud tout à l'heure c'est pas les
mêmes
am de déficit ne lui sont pas alors leur
situation côté finances publiques est
bien meilleure que celle des français
parce que culturellement
les allemands réclament des comptes
équilibrés ç'a toujours été comme ça
c'est pas un sujet politique en france
et beaucoup peur en allemagne ça l'est
beaucoup plus en france il ya deux
sujets économiques et un sujet politique
dans un an dans un moment particulier
qui est celui du retournement quand même
de ce coût de la dette ça fait dix ans
qu'en france très concrètement on fait
des économies chaque année 3 4 milliards
en général sur la charge de notre dette
qui roule parce que les taux n'arrêtait
pas de baisser cette charge de la dette
c'est à dire ce qu'on paye chaque année
en intérêt à les conditionner par deux
choses 1 le niveau de l'inflation parce
que environ 10% de notre dette est
indexé sur l'inflation l'inflation avait
disparu ça nous permettait de faire des
économies 2 les taux d'intérêt une
augmentation ou une baisse de 1% de
l'inflation c'est deux milliards
d'économies ou de hausse du coût de la
dette de la charge de la dette chaque
année là les prévisions d'inflation pour
la france en fin d'année on est entre 4
et 5% l'inflation a atteint 9% en
espagne on est à plus de 7% en allemagne
a donc un pic que certains comme la bce
considère temporaire d'autres dans les
milieux industriels et économiques pense
que ce sera durable du fait notamment la
transition énergétique qui va coûter
cher faut se le dire donc on a déjà là
un levier un outil qui va très
certainement renchérir le coût notre
dette le deuxième ce sont les taux
d'intérêt l'objectif premier de la
banque centrale européenne c'est la
lutte contre l'inflation c'est sa
mission les allemands ils sont
extrêmement sensibles avec 7 3 %
d'inflation je ne suis pas sûr qu'il
soit tout à fait d'accord pour continuer
à assouplir le cadre du pacte de
stabilité et de croissance donc il va y
avoir une pression politique sur la bce
pour qu'elle offrit je comprends bien
c'est tôt pour l'instant elle freine des
quatre fers dont on attend de voir si
cette inflation est conjoncturelle ou
structurelle mais quand même on l'aller
3 0 qui risque d'augmenter et d'ailleurs
les taux sur la dette française ont
augmenté de 100 points de base depuis
trois mois on était à 0 au mois de
décembre on est à 1 % ça reste
extrêmement bas mais une hausse de 1%
sur les taux d'intérêt c'est 2 milliards
de coût supplémentaire pour la charge de
la dette au bout d'un an et 30 milliards
au bout de dix ans c'est pas des petites
sommes et donc le chemin il est très
étroit et en fabrication à la fois sur
l'inflation et sur les taux d'intérêt
qui rit d'oranger rire véritablement le
coût de la dette dans les années accord
avec ça en fait cette période bénie si
on peut dire de courte durée juste une
petite précision là pour la première
fois le coût de la dette augmenté
l'année dernière de 5 millions d'euros
du fait de l'inflation attendant de voir
la facture de 5 milliards pardon et
attendons de voir la facture avec la
hausse des taux oui après sur la
jeunesse des dettes publiques je pense
quand même que enfin je faisais
l'expérience avec une classe récemment
c'est à dire que la dernière crise pour
eux c'est la crise des dettes
souveraines faut pas oublier qu'on a
d'abord eu une crise de la finance
privée la crise des subprimes écrit à
tête et a commencé à creuser les
déficits publics avait demandé une
assistance publique permanente et cette
dette elle est en partie liée un système
d'assurance public de la finance privée
est en grande partie à une détérioration
on n'est pas du tout dans ce contexte là
aujourd'hui vous pouvez que sur les
jours donné notre dette pourrait devenir
si critique qu'elle serait attaqué je
tiens à insister sur le fait que sa
dette s'est pas l'accumulation de la
gabegie et d'un investissement public
une augmentation du nombre de
fonctionnaires massive c'est pas du tout
ça et là de toute façon tous les
programmes sur le régalien justice santé
éducation tous les services publics
aucun candidat qui réduit le nombre de
fonctionnaires et qui fait des économies
sur ça parce que là mais pas sur ces
sujets là où il passe elle va chercher
des économies ailleurs je sais pas bien
comment ça va fonctionner collectivités
locales dit elle mais en tout cas pas
sur ces postes disons de service public
après quand on croit que c'est pas grave
il suffit aussi de se comparer par
rapport aux autres pays on à 112% de
dette sur pub alors qu' il ya encore
pire il ya effectivement la grèce
l'italie
l'allemagne et à 70% cherchait tout à
l'heure c'est combien c'est à peu près
120 ou 110 ans
le l'italie c'est 150 la suède à 39 13
oui la grèce c'est 200 % donc on a on
peut se réjouir mais en fait à quoi sert
une dette a priori c'est pour financer
notamment notre modèle social est ce
qu'on est plus heureux ou est-ce qu'on
serait plus heureux si on était les
italiens ou grecs sachant que ils ont
encore une dette plus importante sur le
pipe et bien non en fait donc il faut
quand même retrouvé raison et se dire
que c'est bien d'avoir une dette même si
elle est finançable même si ça nous
coûte pas cher mais il n'empêche que
notre système il n'est pas totalement il
fait si méfiants annoncé sa griffe est
capable de se dire assez les grands
enjeux les mécanismes mais après la
crise sanitaire les français ils ont
découvert un hôpital au bord de la
rupture ils ont vu qu'un c'est le
système que c'est beau les cols étaient
fissurés de partout et ça vous n'avez
aucun aucun sondage qui montre que les
français ne sont pas prêts à la
condition que l'argent public soit bien
utilisé a demandé de plus de moyens oui
mais c'est là la grande particularité
parce que l'argent public en fait on a
raison c'est dire dire effectivement
regardons quels sont les défis
structurels en réalité le vrai problème
c'est que on vit depuis 20 ans dans face
à des chocs macroéconomiques à
répétition et regarder l'évolution de la
dette dans tous les pays à part
l'allemagne qui est vraiment une
exception si vous prenez tous les pays
en gros du g7 ils sont tous au tout au
dessus de 100 % du pib de dette est en
fait c'est ce que ces chocs macro
conduisent à forcément des dégradations
sur les déficits publics ses moindres
recettes fiscales faisait moins de
croissance fait plus de dépenses
sociales il ya plus de chômage et donc
en fait l'état joue le rôle d'assureur
et donc c'est vrai que ces problèmes là
à dire que remettre de la rigueur et on
sait ce qu'on a essayé de faire en 2011
notamment après la crise de la zone euro
a conduit à une double récession donc la
question c'est comment réduire les
déficits et la dette sans casser la
croissance
ce soit comptable c'est ça le vrai
problème c'est qu'on doit faire des
économies on doit être plus efficace il
ya des choix politiques à faire je pense
qu'effectivement beaucoup de programmes
sont pas très sérieux sur cette question
là on va rentrer mais voilà c'est
compliqué en fait cette affaire-là
raphaël legendre est ce qu'on est dans
un tour de passe passe avec ces
programmes est ce qu on revient à des
recettes magiques où est-ce qu'on peut
compter si on prend le programmes des
manuels macron il ya un bon tiers de ces
50 milliards de dépenses qui doit être
financé par le retour de la croissance
et du plein emploi
l'an dernier elle était très élevé cette
croissance 7% est ce que ça va continuer
et est-ce qu'on peut compter sur elle
après la guerre en ukraine alors la
réponse est très claire c'est non
effectivement on a eu un rebond de 7% et
dernière qui correspondaient au choc
qu'on avait eue l'année précédente qui
était supérieur de -9 là les prévisions
étaient de 4 on sera très certainement
très en dessous des 4 % de croissance
cette année du fait notamment du
contexte international et de la crise
énergétique qui va peser très lourd sur
le dynamisme de l'économie tous les
indicateurs sont au rouge depuis
forcément le meilleur vélo en ukraine
donc
parier sur la croissance pour pouvoir
payer toutes nos nouvelles dépenses dans
les années à venir c'est quand même plus
qu'incertain et c'est surtout une grosse
ficelle qui permet de ne pas trop
s'engager l'autre grosse ficelle qu'on a
dans à peu près tous les programmes
c'est la lutte contre la fraude fiscale
et sociale
c'est pareil on a droit à se refroidir
d'économie 15 milliards pour marine le
pen eric zemmour et valérie pécresse 26
milliards d'économies pour jean luc
mélenchon a droit chaque élection est en
réalité on sait que la fraude fiscale
c'est 10 milliards de recettes par an
c'est là par laxisme de mercy c'est
juste que le niveau est à peu près
stable depuis plusieurs années donc ses
promesses de 25 milliards ce langage que
ceux qui les croient vraiment benjamin
le mois ne parle aussi des recettes
potentielles pour certains candidats
les la baisse des aides sociales aux
immigrés aux étrangers là c'est
évidemment eric zemmour et et marine le
pen 20 milliards d'économies en
supprimant les aides sociales aux
étrangers non européens
là encore on est dans le tour de passe
passe bah oui puis on dévie complètement
du sujet non mais je pense qu'il ya une
vraie question de justice fiscale et si
des économies à mettre en face des
dépenses certes mais les économies ça
fait quand même aussi trente ans qu'on
est dans une logique de baisse de la
fiscalité c'est à dire qu'on veut à la
fois baisser la dépense publique et
baisser la fiscalité et je veux dire
l'orthodoxie budgétaire de base c'est
aussi quand même de garder la ressource
fiscale à flot et ça implique de rompre
avec ces politiques de l'offre de baisse
de la fiscalité des entreprises de
baisse de fiscalité des patrimoines et
la crise du coc vide elle nous a montré
ça nous a montré une épargne surabondant
pour une toute petite enfance et la
population cette affaire en taxant les
hanter
le consensus des 30 dernières années
c'était de baisser la fiscalité et je
veux dire les coûts du marché qu'on est
toujours payé plus taxés au monde quand
même oui non mais il faut regarder dans
le dos
généralement le taux de prélèvements
obligatoires en france est le plus élevé
on a tous touchés avec le danemark
chaque année mais on reste le pays le
plus taxé au monde et on voit que ça
pénalise et quand même énormément
l'économie française et notamment fannie
j'ai l'air disparue les recherches les
recettes la réforme des retraites oui ça
il ya beaucoup de candidats qui en parle
65 ans 64 ans 9 à 14 milliards
d'économies selon selon les candidats
c'est un c'est un levier ou
vu comment ça s'est passé la première
fois non réforme une fine et ça risque
il affine et ce sera un choix politique
mais il n'empêche que aujourd'hui on
part à 62 ans sachant que on a une
espérance de vie qui progresse et on va
jusqu'à on en france on est on est très
doué pour ça parce qu'on a notre moyenne
d'espérance de vie est une des plus
élevées au monde à 83 ans les autres
pays d'europe leur départ à la retraite
légale et aux alentours de 65 ans
comment on peut expliquer qu'en france
on fait on n'essaie de capacité à
financer trois ans supplémentaires fade
avance par rapport aux autres pays
rendez vous compte c'est toujours la
même histoire en fait ce que ce soit la
dette ou autres choses des terres on
doit rendre des comptes puisque on fait
partie du même zone monétaire 1 c'est à
dire c'est véritablement même si
aujourd'hui le pack de suspens et de
deux de ses produits
frais avec les entrées les sorties les
dépenses les recettes qui serait validé
une trajectoire par par bruxelles et les
allemands aujourd'hui tout serait rejeté
aujourd'hui en fait ont ils sont
d'accord ce qu'ils se seront les zapa où
on ne les a pas obligé à suspendre le
paquebot est habilité mais un moment si
vous voulez ils vont demander que la
france soit capable de faire les
antennes trajectoire
comment expliquer qu'en france on reste
un des pays à partir le plus tôt à la
retraite alors qu'on dégage
effectivement des déficits publics c'est
bien on sait très bien que le poids de
la retraite dans la dépense publique
c'est à peu près que 15% c'est beau coût
plus élevé que dans les autres pays donc
il va falloir faire des efforts d'accord
avec ça des réformes de structure
indispensable effort la question c'est
effectivement d'abord les modalités 1
parce que c'est là je 62 ans et l'âge
minimum 1 mais là je plafond ses 67 donc
faut regarder l'âge effectif
effectivement et la durée de cotisation
aussi parce qu'il peut à différentes
modalités
premièrement c'est quelle économie on
génère là dessus donc c'est aussi quelle
trajectoire de moyen terme peut attendre
c'est le conseil d'orientation des
retraites qui fait quand même ce travail
là et d'ailleurs qui se trouve à six
sites régulièrement parce que pourquoi
parce que la croissance est révisée et
donc vous êtes face à cette incertitude
et on verra là tu sais que sur en face
un quinquennat vous avez beau avoir un
cadrage budgétaire quand vous avez un
choc sanitaire de cette ampleur ou une
guerre en ukraine ça change tout vos
prévisions donc c'est vrai que la
question c'est par exemple dans un
programme vous allez mettre une
prévision de croissance à 8 ou 2% avec
une trajectoire de déficit qui devient
insoutenable dans ce cas là qu'est ce
qui se passe si vous avez un choc
financier important qu'est ce qui se
passe effectivement s'il ya une guerre
et donc ça remet en question toutes vos
trajectoires et donc c est ce que vous
laisser filer les déficits
dans ce cas là où est ce que vous faites
de la rigueur et donc c'est toujours ce
que c'est si grave d'avoir des déficits
pendant cinq ans alors pour cela que la
question la question qui est importante
c'est qu'il faut pas tout seul voilà
c'est important pourquoi pas être le
dernier élève de la classe
c'est à dire qu'il ya une épargne
mondiale elle cherche à se placer quand
même hein et l'allemagne ne peut pas
récupérer l'ensemble de l'épargné
mondiale donc les grands investisseurs
vont regarder là où il ya le moindre
risque et aujourd'hui il se trouve que
la france est très endetté certes mais
elle est quand même relativement dans
une position relativement favorable par
rapport par rapport à d'autres pays et
regardons même les états unis pourquoi
même les états unis parce qu ils ont ils
ont fait des plans de relance xxl ils
ont d inflation à 8 ou 9% aujourd'hui
ils vont rembourser avec tout mais il se
bat pour les financer cas mais en fait
ils sont plus nombreux la france elle a
un spread avec l'allemagne un écart de
taux qui est quand même assez belle pour
l'instant vide le gros enjeu sur la zone
euro c'est l'italie quand même hein je
veux dire le lucky à 115 50 % de dette
qu'à une productivité qui est négative
la france est pas un exemple mais on
n'est qu'à une valeur refuge pas prendre
le risque c'est quand même on arrive
comme italie rappelons-nous de 2012 les
pays qui n'avaient pas maintenu tous les
pays du sud qui effectivement avait fait
un peu de la dérive budgétaire ont été
sanctionnés et alors la question c'est
quoi est ce que ce sont les autres qui
doivent nous imposer la rigueur parce
que c'est un risque on a connu ça la
grèce a été obligé l'italie l'espagne le
portugal ou outre un point devant
attendre ça ou est ce qu ont bien
compris en benjamins lemoine oui bah la
leçon de la grèce et des crises de la
dette souveraine c'est précisément les
conditionnalités osterrieth air qui ont
été faites au refinancement par les
banques centrales les plans des dents
gros était conditionnée par des réformes
drastiques de la privatisation tout un
centre de service public et les leçons
du passé c'est plutôt l'échec absolu
affaire clavier absolument de ces
politiques là donc dans toute cette ce
débat de retour à la normale de
nécessaire discipline il faut quand même
avoir en tête ce qui a marché ce qui n'a
pas marché tout simplement et on vous
nous l'avez expliqué on est quand même
un tournant sur cette politique
monétaire va pas tout à fait moi je
pense que ça reste comme tabou pour les
banques centrales j'ai pas eu le temps
de finir de développer mais simple fait
de coordonnées par exemple le monétaire
et le budgétaire ça reste encore un non
dit ça reste très implicite pour
l'institution de francfort on peut le
regretter on peut en être satisfaits ça
dépend de nos quelle position pour de
nombreux allemands orthodoxe pour ce
qu'on appelle les faucons c'est un tabou
absolu il faut surtout pas coordonnées
les deux par le passé si on revient sur
les trente glorieuses une personne de
croissance très forte une des sources de
ce succès c'était la coordination entre
ces deux oui absolument qu'est ce que ça
veut dire concret passe à servir joue
sur la planche à billets d'un côté oui
mais c'est pas sympa ta la planche à
billets s'étaient très dosée et c'était
que la banque centrale elles étaient
subordonnés aux politiques en quelque
sorte elle était une sorte d'un tendance
à jouer un rôle très très politique là
pendant la crise indépendante absolument
le jouer un rôle politique mais sans que
ce soit explicité c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas eu de grand débat sur le
mandat de la banque centrale elle a agi
on a eu un renforcement de son pouvoir
mais ça reste un pouvoir technocratique
précisément l'enjeu démocratique ce
serait de de rentrer là-dedans d'ouvrir
cette boîte noire et de poser ce débat
entre le budgétaire et le monétaire est
la démission met la pression
payer en font qu'on puisse élire les
banquiers centraux en tout cas qu'on ne
parle pas de la dette que de façon il
faut faire de la pédagogie il faut que
les français comprennent qu'il va
falloir faire un effort alors c'est
toute la politique du cantonnement mais
qu'on ouvre un débat sur qui est victime
d'une politique monétaire trop
accommodante qui est victime d'une
politique autoritaire trop radicale
voilà il faudrait poser les choses ainsi
et faire des sorte d'audit sociaux c'est
à dire que tous les publics ne sont pas
exposés de la même manière lorsque vous
détente et vous détenez pardon beaucoup
des pagnes placés dans des obligations
du trésor vous pouvez être
potentiellement victimes de l'inflation
sauf si les supports sont indexés et
puis lorsque vous êtes salarié et que
l'inflation reprend mais que votre
salaire n'est pas indexée sur
l'inflation là vous êtes victime donc
c'est ça qu'il faut mettre sur la table
c'est rentrer dans le détail faut voir
ce qui manque dans la conque les
européennes c'est ce pilier budgétaire
la construction européenne elle boite en
réalité depuis trente ans on a cette
politique monétaire commune qui devrait
être complété par un pilier budgétaire
qu'on n'a jamais eue au sein de la zone
euro qui nécessiterait la création d'un
poste de ministre des finances de la
zone euro de coordination bien plus
forte des politiques budgétaires on a eu
un début presque un moment hamiltonien
avec cet endettement commun pendant la
crise de la copie décrivent certains ça
l'organe avance que par crises
successives et des solutions qui sont
trouvés pour régler ces crises
d'ailleurs faut il
faut avancer plus loin dans cette
intégration est en demies un pas de plus
leur sérieux budgétaire le sujet ya pas
tant d'angoua sur la dette parce qu'elle
reste attractive la dette française mais
le sujet de l'efficacité nos dépenses
publiques parce qu'on dépense ça fait 45
ans 50 ans qu'on est en déficit
chronique on doit travailler maintenant
sur l'efficacité de l'argent qu'on
dépense c'est ça le vrai sujet en france
ça on va s'arrêter là merci beaucoup
merci d'être venu sur le plateau d'elle
c'est fait pour débattre de ces de ces
milliards la valse des milliards des
programmes et on comprend que peut être
une ouverture politique
on verra comment ça se passe entre entre
bruxelles et les principaux états
membres de l'union européenne on va
accueillir à à présent l'une de vos
collègues tient raphaël legendre ont du
monde collègues de l'opinion absolument
c'est sans doute l'une des observatrices
les plus fils de la macro ni elle signe
avec
icm en donnait la nuit tombe deux fois
chez fayard comment emmanuel macron a
découvert les questions régaliennes
sécurité immigration islam in qui ne
faisaient pas du tout partie de son adn
au départ elle nous dira un possible les
proches du président ont des raisons de
s'inquiéter notamment face à la
dynamique de marine le pen bref bonsoir
corinne lhaïk sourires ravis de vous
accueillir sur ce plateau alors quand
vous écrivez la nuit donc deux fois avec
eric m'en donnait chez fayard tout le
monde à cette période s'imaginent que la
campagne va se jouer sur ce qu'on
appelle le régalien des questions
sécuritaires liés à l'immigration à la
lutte contre le terrorisme et puis
évidemment il ya la flambée des prix de
l'énergie dans un premier temps puis la
guerre en ukraine qui fait que c'est le
pouvoir d'achat qui écrase tout et qui
devient la principale attente des
français y en a une on va parler bien
sûr de votre livre et des questions
régaliennes ne vous inquiétez pas mais y
en a une qui a fait ce pari de ce thème
fort du pouvoir d'achat depuis le début
c'est marine le pen elle fait une
campagne à bas bruit sans trop de prise
de risque est ce que c'est vrai qu'elle
fait très peur en macro ni oui elle fait
clairement peur à la macro ni
depuis un certain temps un mois depuis
plusieurs semaines j'entends des macros
nist s'inquiéter du fait qu' elle
pourrait faire un beau parcours voire
même franchir ce fameux plafond de verre
le fait qu'elle ait quand même survécu
ces choses dira la guerre en ukraine et
aux prises de position pro poutine
qu'elle avait eu le fait qu'elle
continue sa montée dans les sondages
montrent que ces craintes étaient avérés
ni un sondage est la force et manque au
losc il présida alors certains solaire
garçons et à ma chronique se rassure en
se disant mieux vaut que les noues
mauvaise nouvelle arrive suffisamment
tôt pour qu'on puisse corriger le tir
mais les maquereaux nice sont inquiet et
le président action attend clairement
l'entre-deux tours pour l'affronter pour
confronter leurs projets et pour activer
ce clivage progressistes conservateurs
pro-européens nationaliste qu'il avait
activé pendant la campagne 2010 cette et
qui lui a bien réussi mais pour le
moment c'est vrai que marine le pen en
mettant l'accent sur le pouvoir d'achat
en empilant des mesures dont certaines
sont coûteuses et démagogique mais peu
importe ça fonctionne bien est assez
imprenable alors justement on va voir
comment le président de la république
interrogé à fouras en charente-maritime
a réagi à la progression de l'extrême
droite sont citées marine le pen vous
allez le voir et ce sondage dans toutes
les têtes c'est un sondage et lab qui la
place à 47 5% face à emmanuel macron 52%
au deuxième tour il avait forcément ces
chiffres en tête lorsqu'il répond à
cette habitante qui l'interrogent écouté
le débat ambiant aco a fini par faire
oublier ce qui est l extrême droite
c'est une réalité et moi je vois là un
tandem qui arrivent clopin-clopant qui
dit tout et son contraire qui reste en
tout cas convaincu par les mêmes idées
diviser le pays expliquer que notre
problème vient d'une partie du pays
enfin ils disent tout et n'importe quoi
un fait est là c'est le candidat lui
aucun doute hélas hélas il a il a
commencé à passer à la vitesse
supérieure
c'est vrai que marine le pen avait
réussi jusqu'à présent à incarner une
sorte d' extrême droite à visage humain
c'est-à-dire sympathique s'intéressant
aux chats eux étant plutôt accueillante
avec les réfugiés ukrainien qui est
quelque chose pour qu'ils pensent qu'il
a beaucoup différencier de zemmour est
ce que vous pensez que il pourrait
réactiver le front républicain pour
faire barrage dans cette élection 2022
face à à la normalisation la
banalisation alors elle n'était pas en
ces termes là parce que c'est un mot qui
est un petit peu je crois aujourd'hui
c'est un concept qui est dépassé mais ce
qu'il veut c'est clairement créer un
clivage où il se met au centre d'une
espèce d'alliance des gens de bonne
volonté qui sont à la fois républicain
et universaliste et qui peut englober à
la fois des gens de 3 des gens de gauche
des gens du centre je pense que c'est là
dessus qu'il va faire peser
effectivement le débat versus des gens
d'extrême droite qui cultive les valeurs
identitaires
nationaliste donc la haine de l'autre
donc le repli donc d'une certaine
manière la rupture avec les fondamentaux
européens alors entre eux et à la
question des classes populaires et c'est
très important parce que vous en parlez
beaucoup dans votre livre celles qui
souffrent le plus de la crise sanitaire
de la crise climatique d'une certaine
manière aussi de la crise économique et
sociale et de la crise sécuritaire parce
que ce sont les plus fragiles les plus
défavorisés qui subissent la délinquance
la violence il a cette phrase dans votre
livre à l'été 2010 9 après la crise des
gilets jaunes on est en train de perdre
les prolos est ce que cette inquiétude
ne l'a pas quitté est-ce qu'il a perdu
les prolos il jamais eu en fait
c'est ce que dit d'ailleurs ce dîner
corac août avec eric van donné c'est il
ya une petite boîte quand il dit ça qui
répond on les a jamais eu c'est vrai que
le vote aujourd'hui est un vote
sociologique emmanuel macron est le
candidat des classes heureuse des gens
qui sont à l'aise dans leur situation
qui ont envie de mieux et pour qui
l'avenir se présente sous un jour
souriant il n'est pas le candidat des
classements pas gagnant de l'élection
sans les classes populaires on peut
gagner les élections avec 25% au premier
tour c'est l'arithmétique de notre
système électrique l'axé ce qui s'est
passé en 2017 et c'est ce qui semble
être en voie de se passer sous toute
réserve pour 2022 marine le pen est une
candidate qui réussit à attirer les
classes populaires elle est un peu la
candidate d'ee gilet jaune elle est la
candidate de ceux qui sont issus de
l'immigration européenne par exemple
comme jordan bardella elle est là la
candidate des gens qui sont au modeste
pauvres des gens qui sont les jeunes des
lycées professionnels par exemple et des
gens souvent qui souffrent et des gens
d'un certain nombre de ces deux
problèmes non parlons justement de ces
questions régaliennes l'insécurité
notamment voilà entrés très bien le
cheminement parce que c'est au fond
l'histoire d'un cheminot face à lui du
président qui au fond ne comprends pas
ces questions parce qu'ils ne les a
jamais vraiment rencontré ça fait pas
partie de son adn véritablement il ya
cette scène 8 novembre 2018 dans le
collège de maubeuge c'est quand même un
an après son élection donc c'est déjà il
ya déjà du temps qui est passé
racontez-nous ce qui se passe est-ce que
ça déclenche comme déclic pour lui alors
il est dans plein itinérance mémorielle
on va être tourné en novembre 2018 c'est
pour célébrer ou pour commémorer plutôt
l'anniversaire de la de la première
guerre mondiale et il mélange à la fois
le mémorial avec des visites de terrain
on est au début du mouvement des
dégelées jaune mais là l'épisode que
vous citez à maubeuge ça concerne le les
risques de ce qu'il appellera plus tard
le séparatisme et discute avec l'une
principale de collège qui lui raconte
des choses épouvantables que des enfants
ont le parce qu'ils sont musulmans on
leur dit dans leur famille qu'il faut se
boucher les oreilles quand ils écoutent
de la musique profane et cette histoire
absolument ahurissante d'un papa qui
vient à l'école avec son petit garçon en
voiture tandis que la maman et la petite
fille qui porte le cartable de son frère
viennent à pied et il prend conscience
donc de 2,2 du fait qu'il ya une espèce
de monde parallèle qui se développe qui
n'est pas marginale le phénomène audace
modernisation et au coeur ça c'est un
phénomène qui n'est pas forcément
violent mais qui est un phénomène
inquiétant pour la cohésion républicaine
la sécurité il en a pris conscience très
tôt le problème c'est que pour le
résoudre ou pour essayer de trouver des
moyens de le résoudre il a mis beaucoup
de temps très tôt dans la campagne il
sait bien que les français sont
travaillés par ces sujets là où il ya
des textes de loi qui arrivent des rues
son mandat voilà absolument dès l'été
2010 est il commence à prendre des
textes de loi il demande
il demanda alors ça c'est sur le sujet
l'immigration qu'il faut pas confondre
et que ce jet sécurité mais il demande à
ce que le sujet l'immigration est un
sujet qui préoccupe aussi beaucoup les
classes populaires il le dit d'ailleurs
au cours de ce fameux dîner et un peu
plus tard ce sont les prolos qui vivent
en contact avec les personnes issues de
l'immigration et les problèmes que cela
peut susciter et donc il prend
conscience de ces problèmes et le
cheminement son cheminement pour trouver
les moyens de répondre est assez lent
compliqué et on explique pourquoi
pourquoi parce que comme vous l'avez dit
c'est pas son parcours intellectuel il a
été lui plongé dans les sujets
économiques sociaux et européens parce
qu'il a un entourage qui est un peu bobo
de gauche de centre gauche qui sont pas
très acculturés à ces sujets là parce
que il veut faire du en même temps
est-ce qu'il a changé sur ces sujets la
réaction dément pas ce que vous dites
alors on ne peut pas s'accommoder du en
même temps sur ces sujets régaliens ça
n'est pas possible de dire il ya des
violences policières d'un côté et puis
en même temps c'est tout elle exprimé
une forme d'un vrai soutien aux
policiers je pense que ce qui a changé
en lui c'est là le niveau de sa prise de
conscience de la réalité des problèmes
et par exemple sur les questions de
séparatisme maubeuge par exemple a été
vraiment une espèce de 2 to le réveil
d'alarmé a bien donné des secours elle à
méreau donc je pense qu'en au niveau de
la prise de conscience de l'importance
de ces sujets il a faim il a changé au
niveau de la manière de le traiter je
pense qu'il a toujours tendance à
vouloir faire du en même temps et
on ne peut pas connaître parce que c'est
encore un peu tôt le résultat des lois
qu'il a qui l'a mise en route mais c'est
vrai qu'il a dû s'y reprendre à
plusieurs fois et que c'est vrai que
c'est seulement à la fin du quinquennat
qui décide de modifier l'organisation et
la manière de travailler de la police
c'est à la fin du quinquennat qu'il
refait des états généraux de la justice
donc le cheminement est lent long et
complexe en impossible débat c'est ma
dernière question face à marine le pen
qui gagne ce match sur ces questions là
à votre avis
c'est difficile à dire mais il est clair
que marine le pen aura un avantage parce
que elle fera porter forcément le débat
sur son bilan et le bilan des manuels
macron dans ces domaines là n'est pas
bon macron je pensais serra de l'attaqué
sur ses solutions et sur leur caractère
parfois
l'irréel ou dangereux mais elle elle
sera en terrain de forces pour attaquer
le bilan ça c'est clair ça s'appelle la
nuit tombe deux fois elle tombe une
deuxième fois parce que c'est le soir
dans la nuit qu'emmanuel macron lit une
note confidentielle qui raconte les
drames des drames de la france chaque
soir il lit les notes qui remonte des
services et qui lui racontent tous les
faits divers les attentats déjoués et
toute la noirceur humaine d'où la nuit
tombe deux fois la nuit métaphysique et
la nuit physique et ses co signé avec
eric m'en donnait qui est rédacteur en
chef directeur de la rédaction de la
grille rédacteur en chef et a marché
merci infiniment corinne lhaïk parce que
on va continuer à en parler de cette
campagne présidentielle restez avec nous
c'est le scan on est à dix jours rendez
vous conte du du premier tour génériques
mervans les dons il y a les deux pas de
fatalité au grand remplacement et bien
molle vous propose le rose dalmore
d'agir pour le climat l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la france orange
ma chronique
travailleuses et travailleurs le système
vous exclus il ya un vrai problème de
pouvoir d'achat rendre à la france sa
grandeur caritas a pas de mystère c'est
le vol
et bonsoir à vous trois stéphane
blakowski ravi de relever comme chaque
soir isabelle lasserre vous voit partout
en ce moment experte de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui en ukraine et en russie des
pages formidable page diplo du figaro et
bonsoir benjamin grands soirs de
mascaret pour décortiquer cette campagne
du point de vue des réseaux sociaux on
commence avec le carnet de campagne de
stéphane alors votre oeil ce soir attiré
par qui par quoi comme tout le monde ce
qui pique un peu les yeux ce matin
c'était la une du parisien voulait pas
vu une du parisien va regarder une
barrière c'est sarkozy en pleine lune on
se dit qu'est ce qu'il a encore fait qu
est ce qu il a dit qu'est ce qu'il a
fait pour mériter d'être à la une alors
qu est ce qu il a dit qu'est ce qu'il a
fait et ben rien justement rien ni rien
fait mais c'est ce qui inquiète valérie
pécresse parce que bon au départ elle
rêvait sarkozy prenne la parole en
disant il va me soutenir maintenant elle
a laissé tomber c'est son angoisse au
contraire qu'ils prennent la parole de
peur qu'ils se mettent à soutenir macron
alors je sais pas si vous avez vu dans
le point mais il ya des entrevues en
coulisse donc le président sarkozy voit
ce tron ancien ministre bruno le maire
il aurait discuté paraît-il que sarkozy
pense que sur les 100 députés sont 102
je crois députés aient l'air 60 pourrait
rejoindre matheron voyez ça s'agite en
coulisses alors comment réagit valérie
pécresse alors elle aurait pu dire
écoutez depuis que sarkozy c'était
sortir au premier tour en 2007 à la
primaire avec 20% des voix son seul
poids a lieu chez les républicains c'est
un poids de nuisance mais évasif don
kelly a été plus soft
je trace ma route aujourd'hui je ne me
pose pas de questions je ne me pose pas
de questions je les invités par
différence parce que j'invite évidemment
une piqûre tutélaire de notre famille
politique
mais aujourd'hui celle qui représente
les idées de la droite c'est moi bon
bref pour berry se passerait comme assez
sympa de se qualifier pour le deuxième
tour jeudi sympa pour ne pas dramatiser
en fait que c'est carrément vital en
fait parce que sinon aussi n'est pas au
second tour bien une partie de son parti
des républicains vont aller côté macro
et l'autre côté côté zemmour éparpillé
façon puzzle comme le ps donc voyez
aujourd'hui on essaie de resserrer les
rangs malgré tout on chez les
républicains gas et de tribunes qui dit
on ne votera ni pour macro ni pour le
pen ea pourrait moore promis juré enfin
pour que la promesse soit tenue keller
qui appellent à voter p4 est quand même
mieux que pécresse passent plus de 10%
et surtout surtout que ce soit devant
zemmour c'est ça qui compte mais pour
l'instant ils sont vraiment à
touche-touche voilà zemmour 11 points
sur le dernier rolling valérie pécresse
10 seulement de ça n'empêche pas que
zemmour continue son travail de sape
vous avez vu expliquer notre cadero il a
fait applaudir la droite wauquiez enfin
la partie de la droite qu'il pense
pouvoir rallier wauquiez morano bellamy
il ya aussi cette affiche son slogan
sans feu nouvelles affiches mais c'est
le même slogan que la campagne qu'avait
maniéré que ce soit pour la primaire
peut tabler ya voyais habile homme en
fait oui le truc de zemmour c'est que il
s'entiche un petit peu vue du second
tour 1 ce matin sur rtl il disait qu'il
se répète au second tour mais regardez
bien la mimique qui fait on sent qu'ils
disent à en présentant et que ça
n'altère pas son humeur de ne pas trop
second tour zemmour c'est votre première
campagne électorale elle est sur le
point de se terminer est ce qu'il ya
quelques jours avant quand je compte 24
avril est ce qu'il y a quelque chose que
vous regrettez
londres au creps avait il ne faut rien
regretter il ya des erreurs mais il faut
rien regretter voyez présente comme un
gamin quand on dit là-bas le parquet
tabriz c'est peut-être pour moi non en
fait là il a l'air un peu sympa mais ça
qu'est-ce qu'on problème il n'est pas
sympathique zemmour dans tous les
sondages c'est le moins sympa avec
dupont aignan et hidalgo ils devraient
prendre exemple sur jean lassalle vous
savez que pour les questions de temps
parole maintenant c'est le tour de jean
lassalle ont bien trop cher jean
lassalle d'avoir fait une accolade à
zemmour lors de la manif des policiers a
perdu la vie vers ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que jean lassalle vote pour un
exam our qu'il le soutien presque tous
frères voilà eh bien pas du tout c'est
un malentendu ce jour là il pleuvait
jean lassalle n'y voyez rien et puis
d'un seul coup d'un seul coup
et tout d'un coup la séquence appel de
villiers qui le dit et j'ai envie de toi
yahia zemo ces bombes et moi je les
trouvais tout un hit ouf les tout petits
dans ce sac de capuches ans je pense
qu'il avait les autres fin il y avait la
pluie et le froid cully rentrée dessus
donc je les paie je dis qu'est ce que je
fais je suis dit tant pis je le prends à
brûler et puis je les lever voyez il
soutient pas zemmour il avait une petite
chose tout mouillé il s'est dit ben
alors je vais le réchauffé c'est ça jean
lassalle un peu de chaleur humaine dans
la campagne merci beaucoup de carnets de
campagne de blacko c'est tous les soirs
dans ça vous regarde un mot à mot sur au
fond le silence de nicolas sarkozy
il ne supporte pas d'avoir un ou une
successeure sa salle idées oui je pense
qu'il n'aime pas beaucoup valérie
pécresse il ya un contentieux entre eux
ils ne supportent pas comme tout près
très loin le déluge quoi oui et puis je
pense que ça vaut mieux pour tout le
monde qui se taisent parce que ça vaut
mieux pour pécresse j'ai une certaine
manière et ça vaut mieux pour moi
content parce que si sarkozy annoncé son
soutien macron je pense que ça ferait
fuir une partie de l'électorat de gauche
de macron donc je pense que le silence
de sarkozy est d'or alors on va parler
maintenant de la sphère mckinsey je vous
donne la parole benjamin grange mais il
se trouve que une habitants de fouras en
charente-maritime a interrogé le
président candidat parce que
effectivement le recours à des cabinets
privés commence à interpeller les
français regardent et il est tout à fait
légitime de celui ci j'ai besoin d'une
mission mais je prends quelqu'un pour la
mission soit un contractuel sont un
prestataire les collectivités locales le
font beaucoup les autres
il est normal que l'état s'ils voulaient
ce qui me semblerait pas normal c'est si
l'état français faisait quatre ou cinq
fois plus que les voisins il se trouve
que quand on regarde les voisins ont
fait quatre à cinq fois moins pourquoi
parce que précisément la pelouse nous
voilà opération déminage du
président-candidat cette affaire
mckinsey elle a même commencé à faire
réagir sur la toile benjamin grange
était partie d'ailleurs un très fort sur
les réseaux sociaux avant vraiment que
les médias n'en parlent ah oui sans
surprise cette affaire elle empoisonne
évidemment la macro ni et le mobilise
les réseaux sociaux en ce moment alors
il ya une image qui est justement la
courbe des conversations dans lequel on
voit très bien que cette courbe elle
saute de 200000 mention à presque 200
milles mention hélas que vous voyez en
fait en superposition c'est la courbe de
mckinsey et du mckinsey gates c'est à
dire finalement ce hashtag qui étaient
dans lé top tendance de twitter depuis
24 heures évidemment la teneur des
conversations vous l'imaginez à 41%
extrêmement négatif et on a pensé que
les médias ne parlaient pas assez sur
les réseaux sociaux oui c'est à dire que
sur les sur les réseaux on a
l'impression que les médias
institutionnels n'ont pas bons par
rapport à l'ampleur en fait du scandale
et dans la manière d'ailleurs dont c'est
aborder très vite on est à la limite de
la théorie du complot d'ailleurs une
image qui en dit long c'est un tweet qui
a beaucoup beaucoup circulé et puis vous
avez la personne par exemple de mails de
calan qui et ses liens présumés avec
fire présumé évidemment avec pfizer qui
fait beaucoup parler sur sur ces réseaux
alors tout ça évidemment du pain béni
pour tous les ans
évidemment les des adversaires
politiques de tous bords se jettent
dessus évidemment etc et ceux qui
réussissent finalement le plus à marquer
des points c'est la droite et et
notamment philippe de villiers philippe
de villiers qui est un tweet qui a très
très bien marché ou finalement qu'est-ce
qu'il met en avant au lieu de parler de
cabinet de conseil il parle d'officines
privées donc on voit très bien vers quoi
il veut tirer et puis il essaye de
mettre en avant une chose à dire le
contribuable paye deux fois une fois
pour eux les hauts fonctionnaires une
fois pour les consultants de mckinsey
mettant évidemment les deux populations
dans le même panier le gouvernement un
peu minimisé cette affaire à votre avis
où d'après les réseaux sociaux au départ
c'est à dire que le gouvernement d'abord
il a eu deux attitudes la première c'est
que oui il a assez minimiser la montée
de la crise et surtout c'est que dans la
manière dont il s'est exprimé à aucun
moment on a mis en avant le fait de
faire comprendre à quoi servaient ces
consultants à aucun moment on a montré
leur valeur ajoutée à aucun moment on a
et donc est donc la conséquence de
toussaint c'est que sur les réseaux
s'est développée finalement une petite
musique une ritournelle gâchis d'argent
public sommes importantes ingérence
étrangère gouvernement qui ne qui ne
gouverne pas la relation publiques
privées et là dessus même l'opération de
déminage dont on va voir finalement une
d une des illustrations
comme elle averti et bien elle est assez
mal perçu et elle donne l'impression que
l a été fait sous l'urgence sous la
pression bref une gestion de crise qui
laisse à désirer et probablement et
probablement se définit un tout petit
mot très rapidement pour conclure la
défense de mckinsey dans cette affaire
mais en fait ce n'est pas beaucoup mieux
s'est pas beaucoup mieux parce que on
peut on se contente d'un simple
communiqué de presse pour dire que
finalement entre 2011 et 2020 ils ont
payé des impôts évidemment rien à donner
en pâture aux réseaux sociaux rien non
plus sur les travaux menés sur l'impact
de ces travaux pour les français le
gouvernement bref on reste sur un champ
politique normal vous bien on est en
campagne car c'est bien une campagne
hélas une campagne contre le président
en exercice est d'ailleurs le sénat s'y
met aussi
penser que c'est un vrai cadeau dans la
chaussure oui c'est un caillou dans la
chaussure c'est vrai show tout à fait
d'accord avec vous ils ont mis du temps
à réagir par exemple la conférence de
presse qu avait lieu hier normalement il
devait avoir lieu aujourd'hui et ils
l'ont avancée d'un jour parce que je
pense qu'ils ont pris conscience de du
caractère tardif de leurs réponses et je
trouve de la faiblesse de la
réglementation parce que c'est vrai
qu'il faudrait expliquer exactement quel
a été l'apport de ces cabinets notamment
par exemple dans la vaccination pour
montrer les côtés positifs de leur
intervention et ne ne pas se contenter
de dire on en fait moins que les autres
alors on va terminer
avec l'international isabelle mais qui
évidemment extrêmement politique en ont
on entend tout en ce moment ce serait le
début de la fin du régime du kremlin et
même peut-être la fin de vladimir
poutine ont les qu' il pourrait être
lâché par les siens certains parlent de
révolution de palais ce qu'il ya
vraiment des craquements dans le système
foot alors en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'il ya des nouvelles
informations qui proviennent des
services de renseignements américains et
britanniques et ces nouvelles
informations nous disent deux choses
d'abord que le président russe est
absolument mal informée par ses
conseillers alors c'est un travers de la
plupart des démocraties mais là ça irait
très loin il n'aurait il ne serait même
pas que son état major envoyer des
conscrits en russie que les conscrits
tomber peu un peu comme des mouches
alors en gros ses conseillers auraient
beaucoup trop peur pour lui pour lui
cacher toutes les toutes les mauvaises
nouvelles et puis il ya une deuxième
chose c'est que le président russe selon
les américains se sentirait trompé par
son armée russe s'est évidemment les
chefs poli les chefs militaires lui
avait vendu une offensive éclair contre
la capitale kiev un blitzkrieg on a vu
ce que ça avait donné au bout de 35
jours la capitale tient toujours alors
on comprend dans ces cas là que vladimir
poutine soit absolument furieux contre
une partie de sa hiérarchie militaire
alors est-ce qu'il faut croire ce qu'ils
annoncent début d'une fin ou pas alors
régime en tout cas il ya des rumeurs de
deux purges c'est à dire que ces
informations sont révélées alors que on
se demande ce qu'est ce qu'est ce qui se
passe avec le puissant ministre de la
défense sergueï choïgou puisqu'il a
disparu pendant dix jours pour
reparaître brièvement en diction
cardiaque voilà il ya aussi le plusieurs
autres personnes se rend disgracié le
chef d'état major
guirassy mafia l'ancien chef du fsb pire
ce soir joe biden affirme que certains
des conseillers de vladimir poutine
aurait été placé en résidence surveillée
il ya aussi des généraux qui ont été mis
sous arrêt placé sous la propre il
aurait déjà pris 1
mais
la prof aujourd'hui était en inde et il
assurait tout à fait les fonctions
diplomatiques
alors in fine et quel est votre
conclusion est ce qu'il faut y croire
c'est à ces thèses d'un début de
fissures au plus haut niveau alors il
faut être extrêmement prudent alors
évidemment rationnellement tout pousse
tout laisse penser que cette guerre
pourrait conduire à la fin la chute de
vladimir poutine la question c'est quand
parce qu'on souvient mais rien ne vous
souvenez des déclarations des
responsables politiques français au
début de la guerre en syrie en 2011 qui
tous annoncés avec une très grande
certitude
il est toujours là donc si les
américains font chuter ce type de
renseignements c'est peut-être aussi
pour essayer de faire pression sur
l'entourage de vanille mais c'est un
béret de le goût de lui conseiller de
descartes et le président parce que les
sanctions économiques malgré leur
ampleur n'ont pas réussi aujourd'hui
ébranlé suffisamment le régime pour
qu'il mette fin fin la guerre mais il
faut pas oublier que
vladimir poutine a toujours deux des
conseillers autour de lui qui pense
exactement comme lui qu'il détient un
pouvoir absolument absolue à la fois sur
l'économie et sur les services de
sécurité et qu'il s'est complètement
isolé au kremlin depuis longtemps pour
justement éviter une révolution de
palais donc restons calmes ouais pas
l'impression que vous y croyez vraiment
ou en tout cas pas pour tout de suite en
tout cas la révolution de palais en
général ne s'annonce pas longtemps à l
avance
merci beaucoup un tout petit bout
peut-être pas il reste une poignée de
secondes emmanuel macron game on est je
crois à dix coups de fil avec vladimir
poutine vous qui connaissez bien les
coulisses dans son emploi du temps c'est
quoi cette guerre cinq ans et 60% de son
agenda je pense qu'en temps normal
l'agenda international d'un président ça
doit être à peu près au moins 40 ou 50%
de son temps entre les réunions les
coups de fil les voyages les réceptions
je pense qu'il ya eu des moments je ne
sais pas si c'est le cas aujourd'hui il
ya eu des moments que ça devait être 95
pensant de l'emploi du temps des manuels
macron oui c'est très chronophage oui je
veux oui parce que lagon d'opa macro
pour poutine franchement
baroque est il forcément puisqu'il est
le fils à la présidence ce tournant a
l'impression que le président américain
pour lui et pour l'instant c'est le seul
à qui a qui parlent alors évidemment il
préférerait être en tête à tête avec joe
biden ou enfin pour l'instant le seul
lien c'est avec emmanuel macron c'est
l'europe en gros 10 coups de fil déjà et
je ne sais pas combien d'heures merci
beaucoup merci infiniment corelec d'être
revenu sur ce plateau avec eric
mandonnet lisez la nuit tombe deux fois
c'est chez fayard merci les ennemis très
belle soirée pour s est fait par et
documentaires qui commence maintenant à
demain
[Musique]